invite more than happy to spread fake
news to smear border patrol agents as he
desperately looks to shift the blame on
the crisis he created biden peddling the
false narrative that border patrol
agents were whipping migrants even
though it's been repeatedly disproven
of course i take responsibility i'm
president but i was horrible with to see
as you saw to see people treat it like
they did horses barely running them over
people being strapped it's outrageous i
promise you those people will pay
they will be an investigation underway
now and there will be consequences
there will be consequences it's an
embarrassment but it's beyond an
embarrassment it's dangerous it's wrong
it sends the wrong message around the
world or sends the wrong message at home
it's simply not who we are and biden's
dhs chief adding to the evidence-free
pylon
we
our entire nation
saw horrifying images that do not
reflect who we are
who we aspire to be or the integrity and
values of our truly heroic personnel in
the department of homeland security we
know that those images painfully
conjured up the worst elements of our
nation's ongoing battle against systemic
racism biden that guy mayorkus and other
democrats are basing those smears not on
evidence or eyewitness accounts
but on a couple of photos and guess what
the photographer who took them is saying
the entire so-called controversy did not
happen
quote
i've never seen them whip anyone he was
swinging it but it can be misconstrued
when you're looking at the picture
greg
your thoughts
well you know i i always laughed at
trump derangement syndrome and i swear i
would never get biden derangement
syndrome because it's such it's an
emotional state so i'm gonna remain
completely unemotional about this he is
absolutely despicable
joe biden is despicable bjorka is a
ghoulish freak
they are disgusting they've become
vehicles for hate and
disunity by pointing fingers at people
who are just trying to do their jobs i
promise you these people will pay these
people are not only innocent and being
subjected to a witch hunt created by the
media and the democrats they're doing
their job protecting the border because
this mindless invalid that we call a
president
isn't doing his job it is instead in
control of the people that helped him
get elected in any conflict that we have
seen so far
joe has al has never sided with the
american citizen and especially
americans in law enforcement instead he
embraces left-wing myths
based on debunked stuff like this
remember the fine people hoax this is
actually worse than the fine people
we nailed it before when when he was he
is a shell of himself and he's operated
by the far left in his party he droned
seven children and three other people
out of his sheer incompetence
and he is publicly more troubled by this
image this image that shows nobody being
harmed this one image of a border patrol
officer who hasn't heard anybody and
some of these officers have actually
saved lives he cares more about this
image than those dead people in
afghanistan
he should be
on desk duty he should be in bed duty
for the remainder of his service
everybody knows this is false they know
it's false but they once again they've
run to the idea of race as a way to
distract from their ultimate ultimate
failures and they're throwing americans
under the bus
you can't stand for this sandra to
greg's point he is now the president
said harsher things about our border
patrol agents than he has said about the
drug cartels
these border patrol agents are stunned
they're angered by this we've had them
on the fox news channel one said would
you go to work and do your best at your
job knowing that if you that your boss
is going to tell you that you're going
to have to pay without an investigation
those comments between what president
biden said this morning
as far as these people will pay and
marcus this afternoon hours apart than
saying the investigation into what
occurred has not yet concluded brandon
judd was on my program today head of
national border patrol council asked
very clearly how can there be a fair
investigation now that president biden
has weighed in in the way he has it's a
fair question and one that was pressed
uh to the white house this afternoon
what stands out to me though is the flip
from mayorkas go back to his initial
response that these are images where
nothing can be concluded other than they
were they were employing the policy
they'd been trained to at the border he
saw the public outrage he came back
showed that he was outraged at those
images that's a real
problem and i don't know how the white
house is going to defend this especially
now that there is going to be an
investigation and they run with these
hoaxes katie because they're cocky and
these hoaxes have worked before trump
rushed a collusion i could name
thousands of hoax that they push but
this one's different because this one is
so egregiously
fixed that everybody with a brain can
see that it's not true yet they four
days later after this has been debunked
by everybody still push it what does
that tell you
that they're using this as a way to
distract from their own failures and
they need another issue and they need a
scapegoat which is exactly what they're
doing with these border patrol agents
it's absolutely disgusting that the
president of the united states will come
out today and not only say that people
are going to be punished when there
hasn't been a thorough investigation
unless you can watch this video and see
exactly what happened and know that
there is no need for an investigation
that the investigation itself is a
punishment in a way to can deepen the
morale in a negative way at the border
and if you look at what the questions
were today at the white house majorcase
has no plans to
prevent this from happening the
administration has no plans to keep
thousands of more people from coming to
the border and camping under a bridge in
100 degree weather the media didn't care
about this issue for months until they
could use agents and law enforcement for
a racial agenda and when the when the
photographer says well the photos can be
misconstrued
with all due respect to him you're only
misconstrued if you're looking for a
problem if you're looking for something
to distract away from spending 3.5
trillion dollars distracting from
hundreds of americans and green card
holders real stranded behind enemy lines
intel in taliban territory right now and
for them to go after regular everyday
people like the border patrol and paint
them as inhumane when they have
dedicated their lives and go out every
single day not to just protect americans
but to rescue illegal immigrants who are
breaking our laws is the first thing
they do in this country
is disgusting so jessica why did they
act like there was whipping when there
was clearly no whipping
i
i don't know i would have gone with the
investigation we'll take it take us
where it needs to go and i'm here to
answer any questions that you might have
about what's going on at the border if i
was secretary of my orchestra this
afternoon i think there's actually been
a little bit of progress so everyone has
been cleared from under the bridge that
happened pretty quickly considering that
there were thousands of people there
um and i will admit and i don't think
that i'm a you know a trump derangement
syndrome sufferer when i first saw the
images and this might just be from being
someone who doesn't hang out on border
patrol a lot i thought like this looks
really weird to me like i didn't
know that there will be i knew there
were people on horseback didn't know
necessarily that they would have brains
with them and i thought what what's
going on here and i do wish that the
photographer brains are usually used
when you're on horseback that's what
she's saying she wasn't aware he didn't
know that i i
how did i know that and you didn't
but that doesn't that go to biden's
point that he's not never been to the
border and he's going to try to visit
you grew up in long island you're kind
of on the rough side of things
i didn't want to say that but it's a
little true um no i i
i'm trying to explain that i i can see
why a lot of people were like what is
going on here and there was also about
15 000 people under the bridge what
about that didn't look odd or why don't
they look down we've been talking about
it all week and liberals have been
talking about it all week and you can
see in the polling on this that
everybody on both sides of the aisle is
saying that like what is going on under
the bridge at the border there i think
it's important to point out that the
administration is taking this line of
the nation was horrified by the view of
these images actually i think there's a
lot of people in this country and more
than 50 who saw those images and said
wow thank you border patrol for doing
your job against people who are
blatantly violating our sovereignty i
think they've got this wrong you have to
remember that trump won a lot of the
counties on the border and it's not the
same demographic that democrats think
that when biden was saying that and
myarcus was saying that they he was they
weren't really talking to the
wide swath of americans talking to their
voters and the majority of them who
voted support it so if he won the
election then the wide swath of
americans should be their voters so
you're saying all their voters are that
dumb realize that
only about 155 million people voted
there are 330 million people roughly in
the country so my numbers add up and
yours right so i'll do the math
everybody that watches it knows it's a
lie
case closed